what's up welcome back to another
episode of get close we brought my
favorite back
david so okay freestyle rap here we go
hey my name is geo and i'm david so's
hero he's here because he's a big fat
hero
that's it that's all i got that was
pretty fast that was actually pretty
good
so that was good i know i didn't say
battle rap i just said rap in general i
[ __ ] up because i the pace went really
fast i was like here's my time to shine
yeah you just there was no time limit
and it was so fast i know i should have
gone slower so i could think drop that
beat let's go let's go
introduce yourself
i care about [ __ ] [ __ ]
save my game at the same time nobody
told you to beat bucks you just said
introduce you
[Laughter]
too much from your man right now you
can't talk and beatbox babe who did i
marry yeah come on okay
okay bring that beat back
oh i'm going yeah yeah i don't what did
you make him drop the beat use a big
[ __ ] hey
[Music]
you don't know nothing you dumb as [ __ ]
what anything you do [ __ ] you [ __ ]
suck you can try to do anything you want
but guess what i'm a man that flaunts my
skills
and i pay these bills
i got my best friend his name is will
he's chinese and he's bald as [ __ ] he
should have used rogaine but he didn't
what
he sounds good
all right so i am your host gio and i'm
bart
dude this should just be our intro easy
for our podcast intro just you dissing
me the whole time that was fun though
that was fun hey i've been emceeing
since i was a [ __ ] fetus i know
you're good you're really good at this
[ __ ] all right so this is your second
appearance on our podcast we're going to
switch things up a little bit
um i we surveyed our fence and we had
them are you good
yeah i just really love these seats they
just feel so [ __ ] good they're really
cool i can't stop spitting if i have my
legs
yeah we've realized that um what can i
put to block it i don't know you but
most people won't sit like this i just
enjoy sitting like this actually you're
the second person that like sitting like
that so we're gonna have a problem um so
this is your second time on the podcast
the first time or the first appearance
uh we had we just
we just got to know you more uh
so on
what happened
you look so uncomfortable and you're
holding on to this i try not to spin
right now
yeah it just looks like you're like
you're talking just like you're bracing
for the secret
like you're on a buoy in the ocean
oh just floating away
yeah so you're a little bit distracting
that's all uh yes so on the first
appearance we got to we got to get close
we got to know you it was from the heart
but the second time around we want to
switch it up uh and yeah we just have a
bunch of questions for you yeah it's a
chance for the fans to get close yeah
yeah you ready
and uh these are all fan submitted
questions all right so uh
i didn't have anything to do with this
and some of these had a lot of me's in
the question so i was like
i'm gonna get myself out of this okay
all right so we're gonna start with
something a little bit hard
ready
how would you handle stress and or
anxiety from social ideologies when
changing your career you [ __ ] nerd
how about you ask the easier question
you dweeb okay well hi okay
wait was the question i was too busy i
know i was like it kind of rhymed a
little bit yeah i was like is this this
guy heard the beat
cause this guy woke wrapper or whatever
okay so i'm kidding i'm not making funny
i just so the question is how do you
handle stress or anxiety exactly from
just like your social ideology when you
want to change your career
i don't understand the social the social
ideology part when it comes to my career
what does that mean i don't understand
the correlation i think a lot of people
um are very influenced by their
immediate circle whether that's their
family their friend circle or just their
peers like what they're doing and then
steering from what they're all doing or
they all think is correct and they're
going in your seat
like that that's why it was a really
weird question
wait what do you mean a social ideology
based on your career yeah i don't
understand what that means and i'm i'm
assuming here because i got the same
yeah well that's your career i got i got
a little taste of that when so like you
know i was like pre-med so when you're
pre-med starting from the community
college level you're kind of like this
group that you guys know you're probably
gonna be in the same boat for like eight
years you guys know
that you guys are going to transfer to a
four-year after the four-year probably
gonna bump into each other internships
volunteer hospitals and stuff and then
you're gonna go on to med school so
everyone kind of stays in contact with
each other because you're just like a
special group you know it's like you're
in you're in it for the long haul and i
remember um me and my roommate he was
gonna be a pharmacist so he's also in it
for the long haul
when we transferred and we got into our
four year and slowly as i was like i
don't think i want to do this medical
thing anymore i want to do this comedy
thing
when i would bring it up like even as a
maybe i'm not going to finish the route
people be like oh really and then
finally when i made the call like after
i graduate i'm not going to do this i'm
going to do youtube people were like oh
wait if you're gonna do youtube you're
gonna give up this medical thing
but but by that time i was already 100
convicted in what i want to do so i
don't really care i didn't have any of
the anxiety or whatever but i can see on
their end like oh my god you're breaking
away from the path this is crazy and i'm
like yeah but it's my life
yeah so i want to take that chance but i
can see it almost in their eyes like
this is something i would never be able
to do yeah maybe this is but this
person's kind of like half step and two
also too what does somebody else's
inability to see what you can succeed
have to do with your life choices that's
their that's their opinion of what you
can do and what you can't do so i i just
don't maybe that's why it's hard for me
to understand because i do understand
when you make big life choices you are
going to feel anxious you're going to
feel nervous but that's with anything
that you do yeah right i mean even
sometimes when i order something new off
of my favorite restaurant i go [ __ ] you
know yeah yeah yeah
always get number one and gonna get
number four oh i don't know about that
yeah because last time i got pork belly
that was dry at this other restaurant if
i go here anxiety is a hard thing to
deal with because i i have crazy anxiety
man but you know at the end of the day
like when i
a lot of people didn't believe that i
had anxiety until on the podcast i was
explaining the the mental process of
what i go through oh [ __ ] that is
anxiety i have craziness i take
medication for that yeah i was like i
know what that feels like i completely
understand it i'm not here dumbing down
how you feel because i bet you i feel
what you feel times 10. everyone feels
anxiety yeah i think that's part of the
human [ __ ] there's a reason why we
feel it like it makes sense i think it's
just us having the ability to to kind of
push it down and kind of achieve
something
understand that the
the reward at the end is
is bigger than this like moment of doubt
yeah right so
also too i wonder how old you are when
you ask this sometimes too at a young
age people feel that their one choice
that they make will determine what's
going to happen for the rest of their
lives i don't know if it's an age thing
yes i think it would apply a lot when
you're younger and [ __ ] but i feel like
even older people because they've been
set in their ways for so long that
they're just i think it's the same thing
yeah yeah yeah yeah maybe it's not an
age i think that maybe that is a person
thing right yeah so you could always
change things and if it doesn't work out
you can always shift and adjust yeah
there's no finite things like there's a
i saw a video of a 102 year old japanese
man in a relay race just you know
so japanese people are the best at that
like the nice piece guy nice
girl outfit yeah daffodil never had like
what's the
social ideology yeah i'm gonna pull a
keyboard out into the prairie people are
gonna think i'm weird but i don't give a
[ __ ] i'm gonna play my song yolo his
name is jojitsuka
all right
i think this person like probably like
taking a couple steps back they're
probably
have been used to living a life where
validation comes from others
so instead of validation coming from
from their research that's even from
[ __ ] school systems i know and i
think that's why it's for them it's
every choice i make i think it's
actually healthy to feel anxiety from
yourself because you're living up to
your own potential your own expectations
or whatever but the anxiety is coming
from external forces and i think that's
kind of unhealthy yeah but i like your
i like your uh approach to it it's like
it's my life i don't give a [ __ ] about
what anyone else has to say i'm living
with my own
life
all right you ready to move on oh
there we go
all right
okay
are you planning
are you planning on acting in a film
again your performance in [ __ ] was
breathtaking
oh why thank you uh yeah
um acting is always there on the back
burner um i plan to hit it pretty hard
probably either next year or the year
after
right now
everybody in this room we have a project
that we're working on with the food
company called junebe this is going to
be our i think that's the biggest goal
is to make sure that this is in every
state so i got to get the food stuff out
the way first and then after that um i'm
probably going to go back into acting
and acting is always going to p there's
no time limit on that i can be a 50 year
old acting 7 year old 80 or whatever so
uh yeah definitely for sure and i'm
going to take everybody's roles dude
let's go that's right
dude
for the acting that you want to do is it
more of
uh projects you want to create for
yourself or doing like the hollywood
process where you go out and audition
for all the other roles either or i
don't care about hollywood though yeah
it's a role that i like i'll take it and
i know it's so stupid for me to say that
because beggars can't be choosing i'm in
a beggar position yeah but that's the
point where i just don't care so if if
they're like hey we have this role where
you you have to put a foo man shoe
mustache on but you're gonna be in a
major film i'm glad to say no
i'm like i don't care if it's funny i'll
say yes yeah so it doesn't sound like
you're going to be in a better position
ever
it sounds like you're in a position
where um you're open to the
opportunities yeah it doesn't sound like
you're a beggar because a beggar would
be like yeah i'm going to do it yeah i
can't be a chooser yeah i mean it's just
yeah i i'll definitely go into the
regular acting field um but you know the
biggest problem that i had with it was
i'm spoiled i got to do my own project
and that was my biggest project that got
me recorded it got me assigned to a top
five agency it was from a project i
liked yeah and that's the hard part i
went from that to auditioning projects
that i didn't really believe in just
because i wanted to act and that was
really hard and that's when i realized
look i'm not really an actor's actor i
just like creating so yeah if the
opportunity comes and people want to use
me and i can make their project better
then
yeah i'm down to do it whatever you need
for me i'm there but i just have to
believe in the project in the first
place because if i don't ever get to act
in another film i could die still i can
still die happy so
yeah definitely not a beggar dude oh
okay nowhere near it
dude that was a really nice comment okay
what's your favorite book i know
years back you're like i can't remember
the last book i read but look bro that's
crazy well i know you don't but you do
that's why i kept it uh what's your
favorite book and what was the biggest
lesson you received from it so yes
you've said many a time that you're not
much of a reader you just don't have the
time to do it you don't have the
patience but you are an information
junkie and literally anything that you
get into you will get into the
nitty-gritty of the [ __ ] details of
it so
we can apply it to anything not just a
book yeah i don't have a favorite book i
just like learning things so like that's
hard to say i i don't know i feel like
the things that i learned the most was
the word of mouth i'm still very
old-fashioned in that sense where i like
taking knowledge from meeting somebody
and having them kind of uh bestow their
life
lessons on to me versus having to read
it in a book because it just feels a
little more personal yeah that's why i
always say i have a friend or i know
this person it's not because well number
one i'm pretty sure they're not
comfortable saying their name so i
always have these stories and ideas
because conversation
is the key of being very social in
learning so i always like asking
questions from people all the time and
the most stuff that i read to was
informational stuff right like the other
night i was learning how to dispatch a
fish i don't know dispatch officials
what's that yeah what is this like
you're gonna fillet it or you're gonna
take them out somewhere so there's like
two separate ways
but there's a [ __ ] you david
there's a comedian here but we're going
to take them out somewhere
what the [ __ ] is your problem
you're the only [ __ ] dude with
headphones in this room that's already
enough
but
i have no idea
i have a hearing disorder thank you very
much thank you for making fun of someone
with a disability yeah you know he's a
veteran yeah and you're making fun of me
my hearing has been blown up by two
grenades on each side
that i held in both my hands
that i forgot to throw
no tell the truth it's [ __ ] your low
life ass sticking your head in a [ __ ]
big ass speaker when you were rolling on
e when you were like 13 dude hey that's
a different bedroom
you're the edc better yeah you go it's
different what was the question uh
your favorite well filleting dispatch oh
yeah so for example when when you guys
first of all what's dispatch
uh killing a fish oh
so for example when if you guys have
ever
went had sushi right they go through a
process where these like sushi great
fish they'll use a process called
ikejime ikejime is it's like the way
that you dispatch a fish properly right
so there is an artery in the gills that
you cut there's also one at the tail end
of the fish that you kill but the first
thing you have to do is they'll ruin the
meat if you do it the wrong way exactly
so you you make you spike the brain
first you make it go brain dead you cut
the arteries and then you bloodlet it
right and so that's the process of
blood let it meaning just let it bleed
out but it's already dead from the spike
in the head okay okay so the problem
with that is that when you kill a fish
through suffocation uh a lot of the
muscle seize up there's a lot of stress
hormones that come against release of
the meat and it causes the fish to
rot specifically with ikea jimmy because
you allow it to bleed out that blood
doesn't stay within the muscles so the
bacteria is gone that means pythons are
eating yucky meat all the time they're
not suffocating it they don't believe in
the japanese way yeah they're not picky
eaters yeah so that's why when you see
these fish who are suffocating if you've
ever gone fishing and you didn't
dispatch it properly you'll see that
that fish is super tight and it gets
rigged mortise
yeah so when you do it with the the
spiking of the head and then you start
and then you uh take out the nervous
system in the spine it becomes really
relaxed the muscle becomes relaxed and
you could actually age the fish
because it won't run so they'll age you
over a couple of weeks or up to a week
and
that's super tight okay well they want
to know about the biggest lesson
they want to know about the biggest
lesson that you've learned how to
dispatch a fish no bro i think life
lesson that's too hard of a question
life has too many lessons okay off the
top of your head where's the lesson that
you're like damn that one was good
when you eat food you eat only till
you're full
and you're done
okay what was happening before you
learned this when i was full i would be
like well there's more food on the table
and then i would eat more when you're
full
you stop yeah so what would happen when
you would continue eating
you get the 280.
that's exactly what would happen that is
my biggest life lesson all right well i
hope you learned something from that
when you're
full you catch a rebound and blow out
all the ligaments in your ankles exactly
tie your [ __ ] sneakers
okay next question
does he miss sacramento
yeah i love sacramento man sacramento is
an amazing city the people are great the
food's great the the lifestyle the music
the art the sacrament is a super artsy
city so for those who are creatives it's
it's if you're in like the midtown area
you're gonna love that vibe it allows
you to create very well so i i miss
sacramento i would move back there if i
could to be honest with you i actually
love sacramento too like as an outsider
going to sacramento quite a few times
now
it's cool because the city feels like it
encompasses a lot like there's a suburb
so if you like the suburb life that's
dope there's a capital where it shuts
down because it's a government job it
shuts down at 5 pm which i like i like
it when it's like
clear hustle and bustle and then chill
versus downtown l.a it's just constant
you know it doesn't matter
it could be 3 a.m and it's [ __ ]
popular we were we were so when joe came
over with uh hannah and i took them to
the american river for us
there's nature around there but like the
one thing that he knows he goes oh
you're for real about how different
cultures mix here because we're in the
river there's like these old vietnamese
ladies blasting me with the super soaker
they don't have a condom and they start
like shooting me with it and i don't
know where i don't well the thing to do
when you go rafting in the american
river is that you bring super soakers
with you so you could blast other people
how fun
i forgot about this i haven't done this
this is part of the culture there yeah
and then you have like these old
vietnamese ladies just [ __ ] dd
mounting your ass with like super
soakers and then as you're going down
the river you see like these cholos like
banging their music then you have this
white family like play and we're all
just jumping off the same cliff together
and it's all fun fun games so you know
there's a really diverse culture out
there that i really like do you see
yourself moving back when uh you're
ready to like i don't like the word
settle down but i guess start a family
maybe i don't know i don't care
i really don't care where i live as long
as i'm doing what i want to do so then
you're moving to vegas
in vegas my eyes get a little dry god
damn it all right who knows though who
knows i like that i like that you heard
it here first
you hear your hair first you're gonna
have person's eyes
what the [ __ ] is your problem you're
like the worst paper boy ever
hey i would buy my newspapers really yes
the worst headlines you're making my
earring oh really okay when is david
gonna do a stand-up show uh
i do want to do my own special i i write
stand up every day
damn
so i have some but 80 is dated because i
never pulled the trigger on it because
you know stand up evolves so do you um
have a time limit like every time i'm
exercising that brain for 30 minutes for
an hour or no i just whenever i think of
a funny joke i sit there and i write it
in my phone
and then i'll be talking to myself in
the house to see if it works or hits i'm
like damn it's just going to be funny
and then i'll start performing i'm like
damn that's not funny at all because
that's funny in my head
and then you know you say it out loud
and then if i do a show i test it out
nobody laughs i'm like well that hurts
then i go back like what didn't i do
right here and i perform it again people
laugh i'm like oh i am funny [ __ ] those
people so like i always test out new
material all the time but i definitely
want to do a special and what i mean by
special i'm probably just going to put
it out on youtube ah okay but just like
30 minutes an hour or whatever yeah just
so i could do it who cares i'll figure
it out
yeah you know like
uh book an auditorium live audience oh
man i've never seen your your stand-up
stuff dave is really good in person
you've seen it
i think the closest thing we've done is
we did a show
i believe it was in minnesota oh that's
right yeah and then i saw david do half
an hour
and he was crushing
and then that was when me and joe were
still doing like the um like chappelle
show can peel style where we should come
out like 10 minutes
10 minutes live audience work whatever
screen come back out 10 minutes live
audience that's the uncles no no no no
this one's oh this one moves away from
that where we do two skits they've seen
before and then the new one that hasn't
been released on sunday yeah and it was
dope like it was people got frostbite
waiting outside for like three or four
hours it was a packed house with a
thousand people and i'm like damn david
crushed it like both with his his
original material and then also his um
ability to improv and do live audience
work it was amazing i know dave is
pretty good at that [ __ ] dave is really
good
so we don't know when they don't know
you don't know when to have i don't know
when i'll figure it out i mean we'll all
do it together too it doesn't matter
uh when you're gonna do a stand-up show
so like you're thinking this year next
year not this year this year's over uh
like next year maybe too soon it could
be next year who knows i don't get
nervous thinking about it i always get
nervous my balls are my balls are
sweating right now and my ass is sweaty
just thinking about it i don't want to
know that because when i did stand up
and i got used to it it was like going
upstage just became the next thing right
and then it was just normal
and then now when i think about it
because i do want to eventually do it
again and have a do a special
when i think about getting back on stage
and not for a crowd of full of fans or
people who know me i get kind of nervous
oh as we're talking about it my palms
are struggling i'm like oh [ __ ] oh my
god whether it's in front of fans or not
i always feel this way because i have
crazy anxiety
i always feel like i'm gonna die and
jump off a building
every time i do stand up i tell you it
always feels to say it has never changed
even if it's like people who know me who
are excited to see me i still feel like
i'm going to throw up wow and i still do
it every time that's crazy first of all
yeah kick ass yeah that you're brave
that's something finally in your life
that's tight
uh oh [ __ ] i got nothing from that thank
you all right
okay now i just feel uncomfortable now
forget it dude [ __ ] forget what i was
getting there's a huge difference though
if you go out to people that know you
you could just go out on stage as soon
as you grab them like no man and the
people will laugh
but if you go out to [ __ ]
laugh factory something and there's like
a hundred people i don't know you just
like
get this full of yeah
the hardest thing about doing stand-up
now it's like
now that i'm older it's i'm a lot more
comfortable
bombing doing the stuff that i love
because before when i was younger it's
like well my normal joes aren't going to
work so i'm going to change my contact
to content to make sure that these
people laugh yeah and it's like the most
unauthentic version of myself so now i
have to be okay with performing the
material that i believe is true yeah and
being okay bombing and making
adjustments afterwards so
because i it's a good skill to have like
i think a lot of comics will tell you
like look at the crowd see how they feel
and then maybe adjust your style and
other times like
stick to what you have you don't have to
change yourself like if these are the
jokes that you're gonna work work on
these jokes i'm okay pacing myself with
my jokes now
and
if they don't laugh
i have something to work on or i just
need to stick with it and see what
happens with it so find your crowd yeah
that's why i i see these season comics
who i really enjoy and i'm not knocking
like new comics or whatever i'm only
talking about this from a fan base
perspective not from somebody who did
stand up before yeah from a fan base i'd
like
comics who are confident who they are
and they don't sound like they're doing
stand up and i think 99 99
standard comics sound like they're
reading off a piece of a paper which it
was like the traditional way things were
done but now we see people like dave
chappelle
storytelling he's a storyteller and
those are the ones that always has me
had me dying laughing
because they're not performing to a
crowd it doesn't sound like he's even
trying to be funny it just sounds like
i'm just sharing my ideas why are you
laughing yeah exactly it's like wait but
you're funny
even joe rogan has that too joe rogan is
just joe rogan when he performs his
stand-up right even somebody like like
shane gillis like if you guys saw shane
gillis stand up he was the guy that
nobody liked because of the asian the
asian comments he made about chinese
food or whatever i'm still going to see
him his stand-up session was i'm a big
fan of him his mission was [ __ ] funny
yeah he was so casual and you could tell
he's this is why he got into snl and i'm
like i enjoy that though that's that's
the type of stand-up i want to be able
to do so like this next version of how i
do stand-up it's going to be a lot more
precise before i just had a couple of
jokes and i would just do crowd work for
like 45 minutes but now it's like
i want to be able to say something so
how do i do this now so if i do a
standard special it's going to be
super thought out how fun
i'm excited can't wait to be fun yeah
i'll open the stage and i'll do my
rapping oh please do it do that joke
that you did about the fish it would
kill
what was it again
did you take him somewhere what did i
say
something like that
jokes all right i gotta write it down
okay next question
what what are your goals for the coming
year or future if you don't mind sharing
also i hope all is well bro
oh you're so sweet [ __ ] loser
that's toxic masculinity right there
when somebody says something nice you
just have to respond with something
negative back um thank you uh
i don't know
did i have my own bucket list but i
don't know when i'm going to achieve it
what about 2022 you got any specific
goals for 2022. oh i got to drop this
weight for sure like i think oh that's a
good one i'm on that last leg so it's
like okay i lost this x amount of weight
i got to get back down i got i i want to
stay at like around 190 that's where i
just want to be at just because i know
at 200 yeah i felt like an eagle
i felt like the sword like the cardio
and everything that i could do was super
fun so now it's like if i maintain a
weight and 200 i was still like slightly
pudgy yeah so it's like oh if i could
get down to 190
um and the weight gold does matter for
people who are wondering about health
just because it's a great indicator to
see what i can do yeah 190 is great for
my joints yes the more weight i carry
the harders on my joints as i get older
yeah so i i need to get below 200
because it hurts like it just physically
hurts to be at a heavier weight so yeah
when you're young and you're
larger your youth is the thing that
carries you around the most like you
heal faster you don't have to sleep as
much but i'm 33 now 34 next year and i
feel i feel the age like i'm not old by
any means but i'm still not 20 19 18
years old yeah so now this weight stuff
is important to me because a lot of
people kind of confuse this idea of well
you're still awesome even when you're a
fan [ __ ] i never [ __ ] said i wasn't
quite i know that i do [ __ ] like that
yeah like i never said i what the [ __ ]
they put their insecurities on you and
you're like [ __ ] i didn't say that i'm
saying like i don't feel good you know
my joints are like but you're a good
person i know like i
could say that dude i put a picture of
my tattoo like the new tattoo right and
someone's like oh cool finally you don't
have to be embarrassed about your toe
thumb and i was like [ __ ] i was never
embarrassed about my thoughts
yeah so it's like the the weight loss
thing is going to be something that's
like the final chapter i just want to
get it done with get it to get to a
point where i feel healthy and you know
when i get married and i have a kid
those things are very important i want
to be at listen if you get dad bought
because of a kid i can't have dad bod
before i have a child yeah yeah it's a
pre-dead bod you don't want that yeah so
i got to make sure i get that [ __ ]
unlocked because i just want to feel
better dude whatever you do next year
as soon as i know that you're working on
any project i'm like ooh i can't wait
because i know it's going to be [ __ ]
fire i'm going to get so buffed dude
[ __ ] your mario's going to get mad
jealous when all these girls still don't
talk to me yeah why doesn't anyone talk
to my man
mario's so confident i'm like i'm going
out with this girl she goes yeah right
all right
all right well kind of on the same topic
that we're talking about right now what
has most of david's your your attention
at the moment is it acting podcasting
kids marriage food
food i i i'm still on that food phase
like the food industry face yeah so that
thing that chapter hasn't closed yet so
that needs to close probably the next
couple years for me to move on because i
can't do something half-ass and leave it
so you know for all of us too because
the junebe match is still going we have
shrimp daddy i need that to do
well so are you still doing food shows
with tim and the netflix show we're
still doing food shows the netflix show
they didn't renew the season
but uh
it wasn't your fault it wasn't you were
you were the only reason why i watched
it oh it did well it actually did really
well but they didn't want to re-pick it
up so the numbers were great so we
didn't know why they didn't want to
renew but it is what it is there's a
million reasons why you never know yeah
so um the that one's done but we have
our own show called foodie calls tim and
i have a food podcast coming out called
something with dudes with foods i
believe i forget yeah i remember that
yeah and then who's behind the food
dude's behind the food yeah so we're
starting our own food podcast for people
who are interested in the gastronomical
world
um yeah but food is like the the main
thing right now it's still that that
world that i feel like i haven't really
accomplished much it's you know yeah we
did the soft-serve thing we have shrimp
daddy and junebe matcha but until that
becomes like solidified in a way that i
can look at and be like yo we have
30 stores all over the united states
then i feel like my job is done i can
move on yeah is there do you have i mean
if you don't that's fine but do you have
like a marker of like when i achieve
this then i know that i'm this i can
close this chapter does that exist yet
uh for for junebe matcha i want 30
stores or just for you to to feel
comfortable that now this food chapter
closed move on to the next thing do you
have that
do i have like a what a specific number
uh or just indicator like any marker
whether that be number whether that be
selling something whatever that means
why don't you understand the third
so once we get 30 stores
then that's it your food constant
i'm not going to be worried as much
okay so what the [ __ ] i'm just kidding
what the [ __ ] i mean i needed to finish
my thought here but the [ __ ]
do we need to talk about some [ __ ] they
just hit 30 many times
i didn't get what i wanted [ __ ]
i just got shot a little bit maybe
dispatch your wife real quick bro oh
yeah dispatch me baby let me just kill
you hey what the [ __ ]
all right well you're not getting
sexting oh no no
oh
there you go
all right is david thinking about
joining the ufc
and also can uh that is the most
hilarious question
do you not know me at all
i fell downstairs from putting my socks
on i don't know man you look like you're
really uh you look like you're really
serious like you're like you're boxing
there was a point where i trained really
really hard and i found out you're
boying about that life okay it's not
something for me what point at what
point were you like i had to train hard
and what about with all these like
youtube celebrity fights going on is
there like a
specific number or circumstance that
you'd be like one million dollars i will
literally fight anybody that's it a
million a million nice doesn't matter if
it's a one week fight camp or a
eight week fight camp does it matter if
or it's just a million is a million sign
me i'll [ __ ] jump in the ring right
now i'll fight a million is a million
true you gotta understand i ain't got
money like that so
if i could go in and even touch him up a
little bit yeah and he knocks me out
it's like once i take off my shirt
they're going to be like of course he
beat his ass
like of course he did even if he get
knocked down a million dollars about
that after he gets he's like dude you're
a [ __ ] you little [ __ ] and i'm like i
still got a million thumbs up
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay next question
do you ever feel a motivated to create
content and how do you overcome it every
day people every day i feel unmotivated
to create absolutely nothing it is
something that you're going to struggle
as somebody who is an artist all the
time it's not about finding the right
moment you have to create those
opportunities every day when you write a
script you do you know that majority
when people write scripts they're not
motivated at all they write it down they
write a page a day two pages and they
eventually get it done and they look at
the garbage and they try to polish the
[ __ ] and they take away all the fat all
the time
that's just how you create things you
can't just wait for inspiration to
strike you all the time depending on how
what you want to do with your art if
you're just doing it for yourself that's
fine yeah there's no time limit right
but if you want to make a career out of
something that's something you have to
chip away at constantly there's never
ever ever a perfect moment there's these
moments with these sketches that i could
have done so many things better but i
just chose to put it out it's okay the
audio was a little off the coloring
wasn't great the lighting was off the
acting was a little meh but i'm like you
know what put it out i have another idea
next every day i feel unmotivated
they're i'm unmotivated right now
do you have a schedule to like
i'm uh i'm gonna do this every day to
like like what do you do to
make sure you still have content
or not no i'm a i'm a relief
do you consume a lot of content is that
why
to be honest i don't even do that i
think i'm just a crazy person like i
literally sit around and i think about
stupid [ __ ] and i just start laughing to
myself
and then i go oh this might be funny you
know and then i write and i go on one of
the biggest things i'm scared of i
actually don't watch a lot of other
people stand up because i'm afraid that
i might steal their ideas without
knowing it you know that makes sense
yeah i want to have my own style so i
think i've consumed enough stand up in
my past now for me to develop my own
style and i don't want any more
influence from all these great stand-up
comics i want to do what i do
so when somebody comes in and they say
oh well you probably like this guy i'm
like nope i'm not i am hawaii i watch
dave chappelle because he's the goat
right yeah yeah but yeah i don't know
how you copy that guy yeah you can't
copy it it's damn near [ __ ]
impossible so uh i i do consume a lot i
i consume a decent amount of content but
i don't really have a set schedule for
creativity which once again i don't i
don't recommend um
but
yeah don't do what i do i think you
should chip away at it slowly but if i'm
writing a script i do a schedule so
every monday i'll write something out
and i'll know even if it's terrible
which is always terrible but then i look
back on it and i'll rewrite it rewrite
it rewrite it so i have like a
mockumentary
funny series about me just clowning on
youtube youtubers i like i have like
eight episodes written out
so it's like but i haven't done it
because it's trash because i just wrote
it so fast so now i have to go through
and trim the fat and then that's going
to be released probably next year i also
think you afforded yourself this luxury
though because in the beginning when
you're trying to come up and you're
doing posting a vlog a week or two vlogs
a week
editing everything yourself yeah you
must have had a schedule because i think
if you're a aspiring artist you can't
just wait for inspiration and be a leaf
because you're going to get nowhere oh
yeah my schedule was every day that's
what it was like i stayed in my room
yeah and i just type type type type type
you just wrote your vlogs or rants like
every single day every [ __ ] did you
shoot every single one of them or no
i shot everything myself and
they weren't really great i don't think
they were but then it was like
the
the type of vlogging that i did was me
doing rants and doing these jokes it was
like writing a new stand-up set every
week yeah and albeit it wasn't great
stand up but it was some content that i
could work on but it sparked an idea for
a sketch it did something else yeah
nothing i held to me was precious so
because if you do that you'll just sit
around on your ass all day not creating
anything at all you're trying to be
perfect yeah it's gonna be impossible
and i don't do that you're right too
that we did work a lot now i'm like
allowed to have a little more freedom
because i saved up my money yeah you
know if i diversified my my portfolio a
little bit so i can chill out a little
more but
now i just
work on stuff when not when the
inspiration strikes but i kind of always
like do that muscle like why am i
writing stand-up every day
i haven't done stand-up in two to three
years i do it just because it's a muscle
that you have to work out and i work it
out i practice my set and then i go if
it's not good or not bad and even now
then i'll go to like the improv and i'll
do a couple of sessions to see what
happens what yeah
i wanna go tell them they're terrible
like i just have to sit there and i
already don't think you're funny so
really uh roll back the clip where i was
she was laughing earlier please
who are you talking to i don't know roll
it
somebody
no that's great i [ __ ] i wouldn't agree
uh i couldn't agree more that yeah it
definitely is a [ __ ] muscle and if
you're going like oh is it gonna strike
today and you keep waiting and waiting
it's like you're just gonna be [ __ ]
yeah like i did this stupid video on on
instagram of this guy like yo this is my
body in perfect lighting and you know i
literally i woke up i turned on my phone
and somebody put it on the reel and i
was like this is the dumbest [ __ ]
thing i've ever seen in my life i went
into the bathroom i shot it i had it i
posted i went back to sleep you know and
that's all that it was and then people
thought it was hilarious it was pretty
funny it was funny i liked that i wasn't
expecting that [ __ ] at all
all right next question
does he baby talk to mario
i think so a little bit for sure
you know i don't know what that sounds
like i don't do like
you know i don't do any of that time
what we did the [ __ ] the [ __ ] that we
do
you guys baby talk friends
[Laughter]
you like this dick
you like it so much
yeah yeah yes no no i don't think we
baby talk that much burial does like
that weird cute you heard her when she
sees something cute oh my god
she tricked me when we first went out we
had a we were very decisive that we
don't like korean girls who do cutesy
like egg yotak she does it all the time
it's in the culture though yeah but she
said she never does it she lied to me
she always did that dude i don't think
you saw it no you don't like it though i
don't i bet you like it i don't like it
because i didn't grow up around it
really because my mom's not like that oh
my mom never did that with my dad i
never saw it so when i saw other girls
do it just like my mom gets disgusted
too she's like what the [ __ ] is your
does your dad like how your mom does
your mom your dad go like your mom's a
korean dyke
[Laughter]
they i've seen them flirt before but
it's how i flirt too it's like how is
that like like tough love like oh you
[ __ ] piece of meat no we just we
always like roast the people that we
love and that's what that is right so i
always like poke fun at mariel and
that's how we laugh and we joke a lot
that's our signs of flirting but like i
don't ever go like
hi sweetie like i don't really do but i
do call it chagi though taki which is
like sweetie and korean oh yeah that's
cute yeah hey tacky and if we get
married it's yo bo what's that like wife
yeah wifey yeah like it's my wife that's
[ __ ] cute
yobo
yobo okay
um are we ever going to see any more
cooking videos from david again i love
them
probably probably not until i lose some
of this weight though because like what
i go to town dude and it's just a bad
idea for me maybe you should do it
before you start losing weight the
reason why i don't do the cooking videos
is because i close that chapter oh you
close that chapter i did the whole i did
a whole like seven eight series episode
series of me cooking in the kitchen is
that when you had that stupid attachment
on your [ __ ] head and it was this big
ass [ __ ] 7d 5d [ __ ] camera like
hanging off your helmet first of all i
hurt my neck doing that because that
[ __ ] was so heavy so i didn't do that
i was like i just like high quality
stuff but i was doing cooking videos
during pandemic because it was fun and i
tried kind of igniting the fire and the
the enjoyment of it again and it didn't
work so i kind of moved past it yeah
occasionally i'll do a cooking video
here and there but cooking videos are
very extensive and it takes a very long
time so if i do do it i'm have to hire a
crew and do it out because i don't want
to mess with it yeah but it also loses
my personal feelings towards the project
which is kind of weird right it's
actually very inefficient the way i do
things i i should to just hire people
out and they could probably do a better
job than i can but i just don't care
about it at that point once it leaves my
hands
it's really tough to
cook already and then to shoot it and
then to also direct it and then also to
like give good content it's [ __ ] hard
yeah
all right
next question
uh what is the meaning behind secret
society
dog even i don't know
it's such a secret i haven't figured it
out no stop
honestly it's it's uh
high-end fashion basics at affordable
price that's what it is so all of our
stuff is cut and so a lot of people
don't know this like we don't
get a majority of our things from a
factory that has a pre-made cut we have
uh a hand in a lot of the stuff a lot of
our materials that we use the way that
it's designed is all premium stuff yeah
like you're in charge of uh the material
the stitching the buttons the placement
like there's not like it's just this
design exists only with you guys you
can't buy it anywhere else yeah like if
we have
we we even have right now we have uh
we're working on our own personal blanks
so if you like the fit of our shirts
right now you have to get it from us
because that's a specific taylor shirt
that we cut and sew ourselves that's
dope so that's just the stuff that i
just dislike that every time i find a a
clothes that i like that looks [ __ ]
sick and dope in the way that it's like
a hundred dollars and i think that's
unfair because you get the same fabric
from the same place that i get it from
yeah so secret society has this idea of
if you want high fashion high-end
fashion basics that doesn't cost an arm
and a leg you can get it from us so and
i generally wear pretty
basic [ __ ] but i just like it to be
clean and simple yeah that's what secret
society does yeah you do your designs
are fire i still wear the cropped um
like the black they look fantastic on
you thank you no they're [ __ ] fly um
and i like that there's not like crazy
ass logos everywhere and it's like if
you know you know type of [ __ ] what's
the website to go to scrt society.com we
have a new line that's coming out right
now a lot of our stuff right there
whatever we have we have left yeah we're
out of a majority of our stuff but nice
our next line that we're coming out with
we have
uh i'm not sure if i'm allowed to drop
this but we have a lot of different uh
caps coming out
i saw them they're sick we have a duffel
backpack that we've been working on it's
water it's a water resistant waterproof
zippers uh we have a sling bag that we
have coming out too a lot of just dope
[ __ ] that i would just wear on the
regular and i think that was the problem
with me doing merch is that people can
wear merch and [ __ ] with it because they
understand that they love me yeah i want
you to walk out with this clothes and
people look at that in general say
that's [ __ ] sick without knowing who
i am yeah and that always feels so
[ __ ] good yeah like when i um
we were driving around and we saw
somebody wearing secret society i was
like hey that's dope they're like yeah
it's a brand called secret society i'm
like
i made it
they don't know who i am yeah but they
bought it yeah that's it so it's amazing
you know that's [ __ ] awesome good for
you man okay next question if you can go
back in time to a moment without
changing the present
uh what would it be
don't say the moment you met me because
[ __ ] you
you know what i actually thought i don't
want to ask you this though
would you ever go back in time maybe not
so much you but for a guy would you do
you want to sometimes go back in time
and re-fuck the girls that you gave
terrible dick to oh that's a good one
[ __ ] girls
that's so hard because i only gave good
dick
[Laughter]
would you should he go back
should go back in time you should go
back in time because like i'm always
like
that is such a [ __ ] dope thing man
but it's like you i bet you're going
around telling everybody i get bad dig i
was 18. i didn't know what i was doing
okay can i make you feel better girls
don't really talk about that [ __ ] after
a while we don't give a [ __ ] so much
that's why i also don't really don't
care it's so damn i'm like the only
person i care about is her so i don't
really care because i remember
the first time i ever had the worst hand
job i've ever had i wanted to cut this
woman's hands off like it was it's like
in my get off i'll do it myself yeah
it's like enough this is this is done
how did you stop no i just let her
continue
but then my dick was getting all floppy
oh no no it's your fault no but then i
was like i just tried to switch
positions just so we could [ __ ] but it
was because it was she was hurting me so
bad so i remember these moments so i
wonder if it's the other way around
because you probably would have [ __ ]
banged some chicks so hard which is
bleeding yeah
was like there was no like when you're
younger too you think oh i just feel so
blessed that they allowed me to
even have sex with them
i can't believe i tricked this [ __ ] i
remember my first girlfriend because
we're both so shy and even though we had
sex a lot we had zero communication no
faster or harder or softer or it was
just quiet the whole time it's quiet
because we're just all so shy and it's
like you're insecure so you don't really
want to say anything because if you say
anything it's like now when you're older
and you're more mature when you say
something it's trying to make it better
for both people right that's the way
you're taking it but when you're younger
when you say anything it means that
you're doing it the wrong way
and then you just care so much about
each other you don't want to hurt
anyone's feelings so you just don't say
[ __ ]
that's what i'm saying dude that's why
it's so awkward when you're younger yeah
and i just i just feel like are they
walking around saying like you're that
guy damn so
women are so forgiving dude like thank
you good thank you guys for being around
ladies yeah uh so sweet in every of my
girlfriend's circle groups we've never
talked about a bad [ __ ] because there's
just other [ __ ] to talk about oh that's
so sweet yeah or we'll just talk about
our current relationship but other than
that the dick i gave out was terrible it
was bad
i just assumed that if it was inside
that she just felt amazing oh god
and then so you didn't even pump you
were just laying no i just soaked i just
went in there i went
but yeah i'm saying like uh most of us
are very forgiving that like if we had
bad dick years ago and then we like
somehow come back to this person we're
trying to rekindle some [ __ ] and it
comes back to us having sex we'd be like
maybe they got better oh that's how we
are dude yeah i know
all right moving on because i don't want
to hear about train anymore
uh what advice would you give to your
younger self five years ago
the five years ago where was i five
years ago
you're 30 29 29
[ __ ] i don't even know what i was doing
i move on from my life pretty fast so
five years ago it was a very amazing so
you never really live in the past at all
do you think about the past at all do
you think about oh i could have done
this a little bit better this time i
could have [ __ ] that girl so much
better
the villagers just don't think like now
those are just fun thoughts you know
like i don't let these things eat me up
so it's hard to say what i would have
done differently you know what actually
yeah i would have gotten fit a lot
earlier
i but 29 was the time that i lost my
weight though that's what i realized
so that was actually the time where i
was like hey i'm done being fat yeah
that's something to live with
yeah because if i if
i wish i would have stretched or like
taking care of my joints more right just
because how hard i play basketball i
don't have these knees anymore but you
know but i've also had a lot of great
memories doing that too so what am i
missing out on so it's hard to say
you know it is but let's just pretend
like it's not that complicated i
probably would have just um done
kickboxing a lot earlier i wish i would
have done it
no i did do it in my early 20s but i
wish i would earn my early 20s i took it
seriously and actually was decent it's
also hard though the instruction just
wasn't that scary it was not i got my
money taken for me dude [ __ ] those
people well they didn't know what they
were doing and i thought everybody was
dope
when i look back at it now i'm like that
person actually didn't know what they
were doing and i was taking their
classes so i just got my money taken
from me and then when i started when i
signed up with fight academy with nick
and i found out how bad i was i'm like
oh i have a lot to learn yeah and so
yeah i probably would have stuck with
maybe mma or jiu-jitsu a little earlier
yeah yeah all right i like it choke your
ass out you wish with my big ass neck
yeah
that was pretty good
exactly
like this grab the elbow and you grab
the side of the earlobe and then you
choke them with your wrist this way and
you go tap tap
thank you the choker taps
yeah all right last question this is a
fun one i'm sure both of you guys are
going to have a fun time uh when are the
forerunner modifications coming up
most likely next year or the year after
i'm not in a rush to do that i know what
i want to do with it i know what is it
what is it what is it oh you don't want
to share yet because it's so fun well
what i've already decided that i'm going
to make it into
a version of joe's land cruiser so the
same color paint i'm gonna have silver
rims and um uh what's it called uh
what do you call those things
gold lugs oh my god i know nothing about
cars you're not a man so it's okay yeah
oh i'm a man
yes
sweetie
i'm a man
but yeah i wanted to look like like an
80s land cruiser with that silver blue
paint but i want to emulate that classic
look but on a modern forerunner
but um yeah it's gonna have to just go
through any rock and possible oh [ __ ]
yeah that's [ __ ] awesome yeah are you
gonna like out of like i don't know do
you have like [ __ ] what do you add to
it what can you do a ton of stuff like
lift suspension bigger wheels roof rack
ladder in the back lights you're doing
all that winch do all kinds with the
winch oh the thing that from the front
or the back yeah it's a motor it could
pull you out of yeah i need a witch for
sure because my anxiety won't allow me
not to have one like just in case yes
the best insurance policy
you don't go with the buddy then if you
get stuck you just tie it to a tree and
turn that on i'll slowly pull you well
the only reason why i know about this
because i don't know very many things
about like car modification parts um is
because we were on our way to a barber
retreat out in big bear
barbell okay yeah i probably said it
wrong move on move on
a barbell retreat and uh this was i
think right like in between fall uh and
uh
yeah what was it uh early winter maybe
it was like early it wasn't it wasn't
snowing just yet but it was kind of cold
uh and you know that lake that big bear
has that big-ass one okay so lake yep i
heard i'm gonna [ __ ] you up all right
so that thing was dry no more water on
it bart sees it because our house is
nearby and he's like oh
dude i'm gonna go in i'm gonna go
off-roading this is when he had his butt
into the lake
so the lake comes out over here and then
it was kind of like dried so there's a
bunch of like it's never dry though
that's just mud yeah it's like okay well
i wish you were in the [ __ ] car david
okay so he's like i'm gonna go
off-roading i'm like you know me i'm
like no this is a bad idea we shouldn't
do this it's a bad idea we're getting
trouble this is one of those houses
where it has a dock
and then the dock goes into the lake but
since the river was dry it was just a
dock that goes into like dirt and mud so
from the literally from the back of the
the house you could just drive straight
into like off-road area
because i don't think big bear gets cold
enough to where that thing is actually
solid okay well david
tell that to your friend over here okay
did you go in that [ __ ] okay so i'm like
don't do it it's a bad idea please don't
do it please don't do it please don't do
it this is when he has this big heavy
[ __ ] chevy with the black truck
um he goes in we're all right and i'm
like oh my god oh my god we're gonna get
in trouble i'm freaking out and then he
starts sinking a little bit and he's
like oh [ __ ] okay it's really muddy so
then he goes over he sinks more to the
point now where his tier his tires are
spinning out and then he keeps trying to
get out and the more he keeps trying to
get out the more he's digging himself
deeper into this so he's so muddy like i
just went
yeah and then
there's just mud flying in the back so
remember this truck is lifted
uh i go to open the door now because i'm
like the stupid [ __ ] i told him
not to go but he never [ __ ] listens
to me you know the wife position so i
open the door the [ __ ] mud is right
up here
so i'm like [ __ ] now what do we do so of
course we have to call who do we call
the cops or some [ __ ] so they can oh toe
company so they could pull this out
cause like the cops this [ __ ]
right here won't let me go
arrest this [ __ ] excuse me why did you
call me
i don't know i don't [ __ ] like him
anymore no so we call it a tow company
they try to toe us out with the wench
and i'm like oh that's what that [ __ ]
came out with like a lifted jeep with
the winch in the front oh gangster yeah
okay so they're pulling us out it
doesn't work that [ __ ] gets
stuck jeep gets stuck too
for the g so
i'm in the middle of this lake they
attach a winch to it the jeep is still
on the dirt it pulls me and as it was
pulling me the jeep gets lowered into
the ground too so now the jeep is stuck
and we're just staring at each other
like what's the [ __ ] worst nightmare
yeah
so now
they have to call headquarters and bring
out like the traditional lo looking tow
truck the kind with the the hanging
thing in the back but on steroids this
thing comes out and it didn't get on the
truck bed at all i mean on the mud no it
was now it's on the street
and uh it has this thing where it
presses a button and these two like
pillar things come down and pushes the
floor like a pu like a push-up so the
tires are off the ground so not now
they're not going to rely on the tires
to be a leverage point it's going to be
these two metal things and then they
attach the winch to the jeep while the
jeep was attached to my truck and then
they pulled it and they're able to again
the truck flipped upside down
and then they got a helicopter
literally it felt like that i was like
what the [ __ ]
ah and the cops end up coming of course
and then they wrote me a ticket it
wasn't even that easy the cop comes and
he's like the sarcastic [ __ ] so
he comes in and he goes
what did you think was gonna happen
it's a lake
and then i'm like
i know
i was like the lake's over there that's
where the water is he goes no this whole
thing is a lake was like i'm from the
city i don't know
i'm a city slicker
yeah i mean you could either said that
or just busted an accent and you would
have been good i was trying to get out
of it somehow i was like i'm from the
city look at my license this is l.a
but it's so [ __ ] different that's how
i know what a wench is
i can't believe you thought you could go
into the the lake
i thought it was gonna be like i'm just
gonna go off-roading and have fun but i
didn't know like how sticky and how like
how much like quicksand it is like the
minute you hit it it just went like it's
so soft too like if you stand on it you
could probably go okay i'm glad you said
that because our barbell team sees this
from afar from our house which is like
what like 60
maybe like 60 100 feet away yeah feet
away so there's that dock that bart's
talking about so like oh [ __ ] so you see
all of them running
nadine leading the pack of course so
nadeem runs off this stock jumps onto
this like dry lake
he immediately seeks it
so when he lands he falls into the mud
or all the way up
to his face
[Laughter]
let's go guys
and you see everyone like stop and then
i'm like bro you [ __ ] see the truck
why would you jump in or a bunch and
then [ __ ] meet him and then when they
pull them out
both of his shoes were inside the mud
his [ __ ] calves were still in there
it came off by the knees he had no more
legs
that thing
was so absorbent whatever you put it
just sucked it in i was like i'd be so
pissed
you but what do you guys do it's like
we're all garlic
we [ __ ] meatheads we lift weights bro
like what the we got it guys
oh my gosh
[Laughter]
it just taught me two lessons one i need
a winch yep two i had 33s
those tires were too small so that's why
i got 35's on the new truck nice see so
now you know what to get on you're still
gonna do it again but this time i'm
better equipped oh [ __ ] my life dude
i'll just get 33's and then not go into
a lake yeah or if you have a way to do
it you could pull yourself out
i feel like the tree would have just
collapsed on your car
[ __ ] that's kind of funny yeah that's uh
that was my story
and that's kind of all the time we got
dude
did you have fun yes it was very fun yes
[ __ ] yeah
i just want to impress you that's all
this is called again this podcast get
close oh [ __ ] david up welcome to
another episode of get close guys you
can catch get close every once in when
days and then after that holy cow
yes yep and then of course guys we'll
make sure that you write and talk in the
comments below about how you feel about
those quote games yep zippity-doo-dah
and have a nice day is there anything
you want to say no nope all right well
thank you so much for being here this is
a lot of fun even though i already know
all of these details it's always cool to
hear it again because sometimes i
[ __ ] hate you so much that i forget
that you're actually a cool person so
having you sit here for an hour to
explain that i'm like oh yeah that's why
i love them so i love you man
the hand of death
[Laughter]
thank you so much for watching and i'll
catch you next time bye